(piano music)
(clock ticking)
- I've been noticing, um, Ali?
Hey Ali?
- Ali!
Ali!
- Sorry, I'm so out of it today.
- They said they were gonna keep me at
the top of the list, so that's good.
- Ali if you don't mind staying for
another couple of hours,
just to make sure.
- [Man] If anything goes
wrong then it's on us
and then we look bad...
(horn honking)
(tires screeching)
- [Doctor] Well, one thing
we look for in insomniacs
is people who get anxious
about the idea of sleeping
itself and that contributes
to keeping you awake.
Is there anything in
particular you're feeling
anxious about?
- Like, why are you even stressed?
Don't make such a big deal.
- [Man On Phone] I told you
about this two weeks ago.
- I'm sorry, I just...
- [Man On Phone] You don't wanna go?
- No it's not...
- I'm actually kind of tired.
- Oh, okay.
- [Doctor] I'd recommend trying not to put
too much pressure on yourself,
especially falling asleep.
- I just feel like I need
a night off, you know?
You guys have fun though, okay?
- Okay.
- You said yesterday you wanna start
working out again.
- I lied.
- Okay.
- Ali, I already told you I'm completely
for you to answer right now.
- I know but this just
sounds like a really
good opportunity.
- For you.
- You know you're not
supposed to drink coffee
if you're having sleep problems.
- [Man] Now this will help you sleep.
You really need to take
some sleeping pills
or something.
- Thank you so much.
- Thanks.
- [Man] Hey, mind if I join you?
- Sorry I'm running late.
- It took me almost 20 minutes last night
to fall asleep.
I was just tossing and turning.
- Jenn said she didn't get your email.
- No I didn't send the email.
- Okay, why did you tell
me that you emailed her?
- You bringing it up over and over,
I keep telling you I am perfectly happy
with my career right now.
- So you lied to me?
I would have stopped bringing it up if
you had told me the truth
about what you wanted.
- Okay but I don't need anything from you.
- Fine. I guess I'll pay for dinner.
- What was that?
Are you that unhappy,
is this that bad
for you to be here?
- I don't know.
I know I'm not happy right now.
- You haven't been feeling good.
You haven't been sleeping.
You're kinda bitchy and
shitty because of that,
and I don't know how to react when you
don't let me in, so what am I supposed to
do with that?
- I don't know, it's been like that
for a long time.
And I don't know if it's just a thing
we're working through, or if we're
just drifting apart.
- What are you saying right now?
- [Girl] I don't know,
I mean I think maybe
we should break up.
- Okay.
Alright...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go.
(puffing)
(soft snoring)